Welcome, curious minds to the
Deep Dive.
Great to be here.
Today, we're plunging into a
topic that, well, it sparks
intense debate, floods our news
feeds, and for many, it creates
this sort of pervasive sense of
unease.
Gun violence and firearm
statistics here in America,
You're the numbers constantly,
right, Often aggregated into
this single, alarming figure
that paints a picture of
constant danger.
Yeah.
It's everywhere.
It's a narrative that can really
make you wonder if you're ever
truly safe.
Or maybe, just maybe, if you're
not getting the full nuanced
picture.
And what we often encounter is
exactly that, a single, often
very emotionally charged
statistic.
Numerically it might be correct,
but the way it's resented, the
material we're looking at
suggests, can be profoundly
misleading.
So our mission in this deep dive
is to really unpack the actual
data behind those widely cited
gun deaths.
Yeah, and explore the underlying
narratives that shape how we all
perceive this issue.
We'll challenge some common
assumptions, dig into the
material you've shared with us,
and hopefully deliver a clearer,
more segmented understanding of
the facts.
Absolutely.
Think of this as your shortcut
maybe to being truly well
informed on a topic that's often
obscured by rhetoric and, you
know, a singular focus.
We're going to try and cut
through that noise.
Meticulously examine specific
categories of firearm incidents
and even get into the crucial
constitutional and cultural
context of gun ownership in the
US.
Yeah, expect some genuinely
surprising facts, I think.
And hopefully some real aha
moments that might just reshape
how you approach this vital
conversation.
Let's get into it.
All right, let's unpack this.
When the media and political
discourse focus on gun deaths,
there's that widely sighted
figure that gets thrown around
all the time, right?
For example, according to the
CDC Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention, there were
approximately 48,830 firearm
deaths in the United States back
in 2021.
Yep.
That's the number you often
hear.
And that number, just on its
own, it's undeniably high.
It immediately conjures these
powerful images of, well,
rampant, indiscriminate
violence.
It's a statistic that, in
isolation, can feel
overwhelming.
Deeply unsettling, really.
And this is exactly where the
deeper analysis of the data
becomes incredibly insightful.
What's fascinating, according to
the material we've examined, is
how that single aggregated
number numerically accurate,
Yes, is presenting in a way
that's argued to be
fundamentally misleading.
How so?
Well, it's systematically lumps
together really disparate
categories.
The firearm incidents, You've
got suicides, criminal
homicides, tragic accidental
shootings, even those rare
defensive uses that end in a
fatality, all thrown into one
giant, undifferentiated bucket.
OK, And this simplification, the
analysis suggests it doesn't
just make the narrative easier
to digest.
It actively shapes and maybe
even manipulates public opinion
by creating the singular,
terrifying image of gun
violence.
So it obscures the very
different realities beneath the
surface.
Exactly, It's like taking every
way people die of car crashes,
illnesses, natural disasters and
just calling them all death
events, you know, without any
context.
So when we hear 48, 8830 gun
deaths, our minds often jump
straight to a specific kind of
tragedy.
Maybe a random act of violence,
a mass shooting, a street crime.
That's the common perception.
But what you're highlighting
based on the source, is that by
not differentiating these
categories, we're kind of
prevented from understanding the
distinct problems and more
importantly, the distinct
solutions needed for each one.
Precisely.
It's like a doctor diagnosing a
patient with just general
illness.
Is it a cold?
A broken leg, Heart attack.
You can't treat it effectively
without breaking it down.
Right, that diagnostic breakdown
is missing.
Exactly.
That lack of differentiation is
absolutely crucial for any
meaningful policy discussion.
If you don't break down the
data, you can't have a targeted,
effective conversation about
causes and remedies.
Yeah.
I mean, think about the
different approaches needed for
suicide versus gang homicides,
right?
Totally different worlds.
Conflating them under that
single gun death umbrella, it
just distorts the whole picture.
It often leads to these
generalized policy ideas that
might completely miss the
biggest part of the problem.
It's using a broad brush where
you really need like surgical
precision.
OK, here's where it gets really
interesting.
And this is often a huge
surprise for people when you
actually break down that big
number.
The dominant statistic, which
you called the silent majority,
is suicide.
That's right.
The analysis from our sources,
it reveals over 55% of all
firearm deaths in the US are in
fact suicides.
Over 55%.
To put a number on it for 2021,
that's over 26,000 people.
That immediately shifts the
narrative pretty dramatically.
Doesn't.
It it absolutely reframes the
conversation.
What this data powerfully shows
is that over half of these
fatalities point not just to a
gun crisis, but maybe more
fundamentally, to a profound
mental health crisis, one that's
often overlooked in the bigger
discussion.
So the gun is the method, but
not necessarily the root cause
in those cases.
Well, the availability of a
firearm can tragically impact
the method chosen, yes.
But the underlying suicidal
ideation, the despair, the
hopelessness, that's the core
issue driving these tragic
outcomes.
And it's crucial to remember,
even countries with super strict
gun bans like Japan or South
Korea, they can still grapple
with really high suicide rates.
That's a really important point.
It suggests the problem goes
beyond just firearm
availability.
It's about, you know, underlying
despair, mental illness, and
often a severe lack of
accessible support systems.
Effective intervention
strategies are key.
That's such a critical
distinction because the public's
typical perception of gun
deaths, it's often dominated by
those visceral images, right?
Random violent acts, school
shootings, St. crime, those are
undeniably devastating.
They demand attention, of
course.
But the reality, as the data
shows, is that suicide, this
deeply personal, often hidden
struggle, accounts for the
single largest chunk of that
overall gun death figure.
And that fact alone just urges
us to look beyond the weapon
itself, doesn't it?
To delve much deeper into the
human condition, the societal
supports, or maybe the lack
thereof, that contribute to such
despair.
Precisely when the public hears
gun deaths, their mental image
almost certainly isn't someone
in deep distress alone, taking
their own life and this huge gap
between perception and
statistical reality.
That itself is a powerful force
shaping public discourse,
influencing policy debates.
So if the conversation was
framed more honestly around
suicide rates.
Then the solutions would
naturally shift, wouldn't they?
More focus on mental health
resources, support networks,
early intervention,
destigmatizing, getting help,
not just focusing on broad gun
control is the only answer.
It really calls for a
multifaceted public health
approach.
OK, So what about the rest of
that figure, then?
If suicides are over 55%,
there's still a big chunk Last
night, the next largest group,
according to our sources,
accounts for about 40% of all
firearm deaths, homicides.
And this is the category where a
lot of people's immediate fears
about gun violence probably
live.
And this is another area where
again, context is just
paramount.
The analysis details that the
primary drivers of these
homicides, they are almost
universally linked to very
specific circumstances like what
predominantly involving
individuals already engaged in
criminal activity, gang related
violence or tragically deep
personal domestic disputes.
OK, so that's a crucial
distinction that often gets
glossed over.
Absolutely.
These are, by and large, not
random acts against strangers
committed by otherwise lawful
law abiding citizens.
That's not to diminish the
tragedy, of course not.
But it's about understanding the
nature of these events and the
specific environments where they
happen.
So the picture that emerges is
less about some random
omnipresent threat lurking
everywhere, yeah, and more about
targeted, often pre-existing
conflicts or high risk
situations like rival gangs,
people involved in crime, or
really intense, tragic domestic
situations.
That's what the data points to.
These circumstances really
dictate the nature of the
violence.
And that different
differentiation is vital, then,
for understanding the root
causes.
It suggests that maybe broad,
sweeping gun laws might miss the
mark if they don't specifically
address those drivers.
The socioeconomic issues, the
criminal networks, the
interpersonal conflicts.
That's the crux of the argument
presented in the material.
When you grasp that nearly all
firearm homicides are criminal,
on criminal, gang related, or
domestic, that sweeping blanket
gun violence label, it becomes
way less helpful, actually
misleading.
The material argues these
incidents are fundamentally
different in nature and cause
from what that general label
implies.
For instance, if most homicides
are coming from gang activity in
specific areas.
In the solutions look different.
Exactly.
Effective solutions would
involve things like robust unity
policing, creating real economic
opportunities, dismantling
criminal networks, targeted
interventions in those high risk
zones.
Rather than just restricting gun
access for everybody.
Right.
It calls for, you know, surgical
precision and policy, not these
broad strokes that often fail to
hit the core problem.
What about those tragic
accidents we hear about?
We often see news stories about
accidental shootings, especially
involving children.
And they are.
I mean, they're just
heartbreaking.
Unquestionably heartbreaking.
They leave such a deep
impression depression and
understandably add to the
overall anxiety around guns.
They do.
Those incidents are incredibly
tragic, and they grab our
attention and sympathy, as they
should.
But when we look at the actual
data provided in the sources,
accidental shootings make up a
statistically tiny portion of
overall firearm deaths.
How tiny?
In 2021, the numbers show just
549 such incidents. 549 That
number feels stark in isolation,
but I guess it becomes even more
striking when you put it in the
context of how many guns there
are in the US.
Absolutely.
And the material we're looking
at highlights exactly that.
Compare 549 incidents to the
immense number of privately
owned firearms, estimated over
450 million.
Wow, over 450 million guns.
Yeah, so when you have nearly
half a billion firearms out
there, but only 549 accidental
deaths in a whole year, the risk
for most individuals is actually
vanishingly small.
That doesn't mean we shouldn't
aim for zero accidents,
obviously.
Not at all.
We should always strive for zero
through rigorous gun safety
education, responsible training,
secure storage.
All of that is vital, but it
strongly challenges the idea
that firearms themselves are
inherently causing widespread
accidental deaths all the time.
The data just doesn't back up
that level of constant pervasive
accidental risk.
OK, this raises another really
important question, one that
often feels overlooked in the
broader conversation.
What's that?
What about guns used for
self-defense?
We hear so much about firearms
as instruments of violence, but
far less about their role
potentially in protection and
preventing harm.
That's a profoundly important
point, and it's a critical piece
of the puzzle that, according to
the sources, is frequently just
omitted from the public
discourse.
So defensive gun uses or DG us.
Right.
Those DG us that unfortunately
result in an attacker's death,
They barely register in the
overall homicide stats, mainly
because if they're justifiable,
they get categorized
differently.
But the sources point to
extensive work by criminologist
Gary Kleck.
His research indicates that
defensive gun uses might number
in the 100 of thousands, maybe
even 1,000,000 per year.
Millions.
That figure, even at the low
end, is massive compared to
criminal homicides or accidents.
It's.
Huge We're talking about
situations where a firearm is
used, often legally and
justifiably, to prevent a crime
or stop an attacker, potentially
saving lives.
And these instances, Kleck
argues, are happening way more
often than criminal acts or
accidents involving guns.
That's a really powerful counter
narrative.
It is, and here's a crucial
insight from Kleck's research,
as cited in our material.
Most DGU's they end without a
shot even being fired.
Really, just showing the gun is
enough.
Often, yes, the mere presence of
the firearm or just the verbal
threat of using it is frequently
enough to deter the criminal and
stop the crime from escalating.
This is a vital, yet very often
overlooked aspect of firearm
use.
And it challenges that singular
narrative of guns purely as
tools of violence.
Profoundly, the analysis argues,
this category is consistently
omitted or downplayed in public
discussions, contributing
directly to what it calls a
manufactured narrative of fear.
How so?
Well, if the public only ever
hears about the violence caused
by guns, and never hears about
the successful prevention of
violence or defense of self and
on others using guns, it creates
A deeply skewed perception of
firearms and their role in
society.
So when we simplify this
sometimes to the idea of guns is
just tools, it feels almost too
simple for something with such
huge implications.
How does that perspective as the
source presents it really tie
into this?
It might sound simplistic, yeah,
but it's a core argument the
sources make.
They draw on an analogy from
commentator Colean Noir.
Noir basically says, look, every
society uses its tools.
And in the US, where guns are
widespread, doubling green
culturally, they're naturally
going to be present in both
crimes and defenses.
Like a car, a tool for
transport, but can be a weapon
for a drunk driver.
Exactly.
Or a knife, a kitchen tool, but
potentially an instrument of
violence.
The tool itself is inert.
Its use, its ethical weight, is
determined by the intent and
actions of the person holding
it.
So the core argument here from
the source material is that
conflating, say, a homeowner
using a gun to defend their
family from an intruder.
Which is a morally and legally
justifiable act often.
Right.
Conflating that with a purely
criminal act, like a gang member
shot in a turf war, that's an
intentional move in public
discourse.
Yes, the analysis we've reviewed
argues that this conflation is
intentional.
It serves to simplify the
narrative, making it easier to
manipulate public opinion by
presenting all gun deaths as if
they're equivalent and tragedies
caused solely by the guns
themselves.
But there's a clear moral and
legal difference.
Undeniably, one is an act of
defense, often legally
protected, socially sanctioned
even.
The other is a criminal act with
totally different motivations
and consequences.
Lumping them together under 1
gun death statistic, it just
blurs those critical lines,
fuels this undifferentiated
fear, and ultimately hinders an
honest look at the different
types of firearm incidents and
their very distinct causes.
It's about crafting an
impression, the source argues,
not illuminating the complex
truth.
OK, let's shift slightly and
talk about something that
creates just a profound amount
of anxiety for so many of us,
especially parents.
The haunting idea of a school
shooter.
It's a terrifying image.
It can lead to immense fear,
this feeling of constant
vulnerability in places that
should be the absolute safest.
And that's precisely what the
analysis addresses head on.
It presents a really striking,
almost counterintuitive
statistic, which is the
likelihood of any specific
child's school being attacked in
any given year is less than one
in 2 million.
Less than one in 2 million.
Extremely low statistical
probability.
Yet, as you rightly point out,
the public perception is often
one of an omnipresent,
immediate, pervasive threat.
So how does that happen?
The material attributes this
huge gap between the tiny
statistical reality and the
widespread fear to something it
calls fear amplification.
Right.
And if the actual statistical
likelihood is so incredibly low,
how is this feeling of threat
amplified so much?
What are the mechanisms creating
this disconnect?
Yeah.
What does the analysis say
drives that amplification?
It details several methods.
It points to the widespread use
of school shooting drills which
have become, you know, a regular
part of a kids school experience
now.
Right active shooter drill.
Yeah, yeah.
It also highlights relentless
media saturation.
Every incident, no matter how
isolated, often gets extensive,
repetitive coverage, creating
the sense of it happening all
the time, everywhere.
And finally, it identifies what
it calls political
grandstanding, where the issue
is used for rhetorical leverage.
The source claims these aren't
just isolated things.
These methods actively amplify
fear beyond all proportion and
using very strong language,
weaponize it.
Weaponize fear.
Yeah, the intention, it argues,
goes beyond just being prepared.
These drills in particular are
described as not just preparing
kids for a rare event, but
actively indoctrinating.
Them indoctrinating?
Wow, that's a really strong
word.
Exactly.
Does the analysis mean by that?
What are the implications?
It means embedding in children
this deep, almost subconscious
belief that danger is constant,
that they're perpetually at
risk, regardless of the actual
statistics saying otherwise.
I mean, imagine the repeated
physical and emotional stress of
preparing for this terrifying
the rare scenario year after
year from a young age.
Yeah, it would have an impact.
Even if intellectually a kid
knows it's unlikely, that
repetitive stress, that focus,
it can imprint this sense of
imminent vulnerability ability.
It fosters anxiety and shapes
their view of the world in a way
that's maybe disproportionate to
the actual threat.
And this, the analysis argues,
then serves to maintain and
heighten public fear, creating
fertile ground for certain
policy narratives.
Exactly.
It moves beyond just preparation
into, well, psychological
conditioning, according to this
view.
So connecting this to the bigger
picture, the material uses that
very strong phrase, the
manufactured crisis.
That's a bold claim suggesting A
deliberate construction of how
we see things.
It is a bold claim, yeah, and
the material backs it up by
circling back to the sheer
number of privately owned
firearms in the US That
staggering figure?
Over 450 million, the analysis
argues.
Look, if the mere presence of
guns automatically cause rampant
violence, America would
essentially be a war zone, a
perpetually chaotic
battleground.
But it's not.
The reality is the vast majority
of these firearms are owned by
lawful citizens.
They're never involved in crime,
accidents or suicides.
They're stored securely or used
for legitimate, lawful reasons.
So the conclusion, according to
this analysis, is that the
epidemic of gun violence isn't
some organic truth just bubbling
up from the numbers, right?
But it's more of a rhetorical
creation, inflated by lumping
statistics together like we
talked about, and significantly,
by fear mongering that taps into
our deep anxieties.
Exactly when you analytically
pull out suicides, accidents,
and criminal on criminal
violence from that overall gun
death data, what's left, the
analysis argues, is a society
where lawful citizens
overwhelmingly use firearms
responsibly, safely, and often
for defense.
Leads to a key discussion point
from the material.
Yeah, that policy debates, if
they're going to be effective,
truly serve the public, they
need to be grounded in honesty.
They need to focus on the root
causes of violence.
Like mental illness, gang
culture, specific criminal
behaviors driven by other social
and economic factors.
Precisely.
Rather than just advocating for
these blanket restrictions that
hit the vast majority of
responsible gun owners, the
manufactured crisis narrative in
this view basically serves to
divert attention from genuine
targeted solutions by creating
this simplified, alarmist
picture of the problem.
OK, let's shift gears a bit now
and consider the just staggering
number of firearms in private
hands across America.
It's a statistic that, on its
own, can be pretty overwhelming
to even comprehend.
It truly is.
The United States is home to an
estimated 450 to 500 million
privately owned firearms.
Half a billion potentially.
Potentially that's more guns
than people in the country.
It's a scale of ownership just
unmatched anywhere else in the
world by a huge margin, right.
And what's really remarkable, as
the analysis highlights, is
despite this absolutely vast
arsenal, this huge number of
weapons in civilian hands, only
a tiny miniscule fraction are
ever.
Involved in crimes, homicides or
even accidents.
The overwhelming majority, they
say, securely stored, used for
sport collecting.
Lawful self-defense completely
outside any criminal context.
It really defies a simple,
direct link between just the
number of guns and the level of
violence.
So why is this number so
incredibly high then?
Is it because of widespread
criminality?
A nation of people just waiting
to cause harm?
Or is it something else we might
not immediately think of?
Well, the material we're looking
at argues pretty strongly it's
not due to rampant criminality
or intent to misuse them.
Instead, it offers this analogy
that kind of brings it into
focus.
OK, think of firearms ownership
in America as often being like
owning A diverse set of golf
clubs, or maybe a comprehensive
box of specialized tools for
different jobs.
Right, you don't just have one
hammer if you're a Carpenter.
Exactly.
Each firearm for many owners
serves a unique, distinct role.
For instance, you might have a
compact handgun specifically for
concealed carry for personal
protection outside the home.
Then maybe a different shotgun
kept purely for home defense, A
specialized hunting rifle for
deer season.
Maybe a precision rifle for a
competitive long range shooting?
And collectors too, right?
Absolutely.
And then you have dedicated
collectors who might own dozens,
maybe hundreds of firearms
simply for their historical
value, their craftsmanship,
maybe as an investment with 0
intention of ever using them
violently.
So it's this multiplicity of
legitimate purpose that really
inflates the count, not a
proliferation of criminals.
That's the argument.
It's like looking at that master
Carpenter with a garage full of
different saws and drills and
concluding they must be
constantly building or
destroying things When?
Really, they just have the right
tool for each specific job, and
some tools might hardly ever get
used.
Precisely.
The analysis emphasizes that
this diverse set of legitimate
uses and deep cultural interests
is what primarily drives the
high number.
It fundamentally challenges the
assumption that a high count
automatically means higher
criminal activity.
It reframes this vast arsenal
from being inherently dangerous
to being an indicator of a deep
cultural practice, a
constitutional right, and a
bunch of lawful, often
specialized activities.
Correlation isn't causation,
basically.
OK, here's where it gets really
fascinating when we look at the
legal landscape around firearms,
because it often runs directly
counter to the narrative we
usually hear about America
supposedly tightening gun
control.
That's a profoundly significant
point, and it reflects A
dramatic, often underreported
legal and cultural shift that's
been happening.
Also.
The material details this huge
transformation since the 1980s.
Back then, only a handful of
states allowed ordinary law
abiding citizens to carry
concealed handguns easily
without major hurdles.
OK.
So it was pretty restrictive
generally.
Yeah, Fast forward to today,
that picture is fundamentally
different.
As of now, at least 27 states,
well over half the country, have
enacted constitutional carry or
permit list carry laws, meaning
eligible citizens can carry
concealed firearms without
needing a government issued
permit.
It reflects this profound shift
towards greater firearm freedoms
for individuals in many parts of
the country.
So despite all the public
debate, the impassioned calls
for stricter laws, the
headlines, the legal reality in
many states has actually moved
decisively in the opposite
direction.
That's what the trend shows.
That really does run counter to
the narrative of America just
constantly tightening gun
control.
It absolutely does.
The legal environment has
steadily significantly loosened
over the past four decades, and
this trend has been powerfully
reinforced by landmark Supreme
Court decisions.
The courts.
Yeah, these rulings, which we
should get into, have profoundly
reshaped how the 2nd Amendment
is interpreted.
They've affirmed it as an
individual right, not just tied
to state militias.
And that judicial backing has
been critical for allowing these
state level legislative shifts.
So what does this all mean for
that foundational legal right to
bear arms?
Sounds like the Supreme Court
has played a really pivotal role
here.
Monumental really, Unequivocally
fortifying the Second Amendment,
specifically landmark decisions
like District of Columbia V
Heller in 2008, Right?
I don't.
Remember that one?
And more recently, New York
State Rifle and Pistol
Association V Bruin in 2022.
These have profoundly impacted
the interpretation, the material
says.
These rulings have fortified the
Second Amendment against
legislative encroachment,
basically making it much harder
for legislators to pass broad
gun control measures that
infringe on this individual
right.
So Heller established the
individual right for
self-defense in the home.
Exactly.
That was groundbreaking, and
Bruin then extended that
protection, saying the right to
carry a handgun for self-defense
applies outside the home, too.
That struck down those may issue
concealed carry laws where
officials had broad discretion
to just say no.
So these cases represent a
fundamental shift in the legal
understanding A.
Huge shift in legal precedent,
yeah.
OK, what about efforts to ban
certain types of firearms,
particularly what are often
called assault weapons?
Those are frequently right at
the center of debates,
especially after a high profile
incidents.
Right.
That's often seen as a key
battleground.
Yeah.
The analysis addresses this
directly, giving crucial
historical and legal context.
It notes the federal assault
weapons ban enacted back in 94.
It actually expired in 2004.
And it's never been brought back
federally.
Never successfully reinstated at
the federal level despite
ongoing attempts consistent
public calls from some quarters,
the material asserts.
The political winds have just
constantly shifted, making
sweeping federal restrictions
like that highly unlikely right
now.
And the courts?
Furthermore, the courts are
described as increasingly
sympathetic to an expansive
interpretation of the Second
Amendment.
They've actively dismantled many
existing limits and signaled
deep skepticism toward future
bans on certain types of
firearms.
So a strong judicial stance plus
the political landscape creates
a different reality than maybe
the headlines suggest.
That's the argument.
It suggests a significant legal
barrier to broad federal bans,
very different from what many
might assume.
OK.
Let's really unpack this core
idea, the one underpinning so
much of this the actual purpose
of the Second Amendment.
Most people when they think
right to bear arms, they
probably think hunting, target
practice, maybe home defense.
Right, those are the common
associations today.
But the analysis we've reviewed
suggests the framers had
something much more profound,
maybe even revolutionary, in
mind.
That's absolutely right, the
analysis argues.
Look closely at the actual text.
A well regulated Militia, being
necessary to the security of a
Free State, the right of the
people to keep and bear arms,
shall not be infringed.
It conspicuously doesn't mention
hunting or target practice, or
even direct home defense.
While those uses are culturally
big now, the material contends,
they are, as the source puts it,
incidental to its core purpose.
Which was the primary emphasis,
the analysis contends, was
ensuring the citizenry could, if
necessary, resist potential
tyranny.
So it's fundamentally about a
check on government power that
connects directly to the
historical context, the founding
of the nation.
Like the historical context
isn't just important, it's
crucial.
They had just fought A brutal
war against a powerful
centralized government that had
disarmed people.
They knew first hand the dangers
of an oppressive regime.
They understood deeply A
disarmed populace is a
vulnerable 1, susceptible to
government overreach.
Their core belief, according to
this analysis, was that an armed
populist serves as a vital check
against unchecked power.
A principle the material claims
has been downplayed or obscured
in today's debates.
Significantly downplayed, even
intentionally obscured, is the
argument this wasn't about sport
or recreation for them.
It was about a final, ultimate
line of defense for a Free
State, ensuring the government
ultimately stays accountable to
the people.
But critics often argue that
whole militia reference makes it
obsolete.
Now we have professional
standing armies.
Why would individual citizens
need to be armed like the
Founders envisioned, seemingly
for military purposes?
That's a very common argument,
yeah, and the analysis
acknowledges it directly.
However, it reiterates that the
courts, especially the Supreme
Court in Heller and Bruin, have
consistently affirmed the right
belongs to individuals, not just
some state organized militia.
And while the analysis notes,
look, nobody realistically
expects civilians to square off
against a modern military, it
asserts the principle remains
profoundly relevant.
The principle of an armed
populace as a check on potential
government overreach, even if
the nature of that check has
evolved from muskets to modern
arms, is still foundational to
the Second Amendment's purpose.
It's about ensuring ultimate
power.
Ultimate recourse remains with
the people, not just the state.
This brings up that important
question about modern weapons
though.
Opponents often argue the
founders couldn't possibly if
foreseen today's semi automatics
making the Second Amendment
irrelevant to them or needing
strict reinterpretation.
You hear that a lot.
You do, and the analysis
presents a really compelling
counter argument.
It suggests that line of
reasoning of fundamentally
misunderstands the very nature
of rights themselves.
It uses a powerful, relatable
analogy, the First Amendment
freedom of speech and press.
It was explicitly written in the
age of quill pens, parchment,
slow printing presses.
Yet nobody seriously argues
today that the First Amendment
doesn't protect speech on the
Internet or TV broadcasts or
podcasts or new digital
communication.
The right itself goes beyond the
specific technology of its
origin.
So the right adapts to
technology because it's rooted
in a timeless principle, not the
specific hardware of the time it
was written.
It's about the spirit of the
right, not just the physical
means.
Exactly the principle of free
expression applies regardless of
the medium.
Similarly, the principle of the
right to bear arms as a
safeguard for liberty,
individual self-defense should
logically adapt to the
contemporary tools embodying
that principle.
Argue otherwise would kind of
freeze rights in time, make them
obsolete?
That's the contention.
It would render them meaningless
as technology progresses.
It's about the spirit of the
right ensuring it stays
relevant, not narrowly confining
it only to the weapons available
back then.
What's truly fascinating here,
and maybe a bit ironic, is how
arbitrary some legal definitions
can actually be, especially when
they clash with common
understanding or even the
history we've just discussed.
This is a really intriguing
detail from the material.
It underscores that
arbitrariness.
It highlights that the very
weapons the founders did know,
like muzzle loaded black powder
rifles, historical firearms like
that they aren't even considered
firearms under the main current
federal definitions used by the
BTFE, Bureau of Alcohol,
Tobacco, Firearms and
Explosives, or the National
Firearms Act.
Wait, seriously?
A flintlock musket, the kind of
gun used in the revolution,
isn't regulated like a modern
firearm today?
That's wild.
That's precisely correct.
A flintlock musket.
Many antique black powder guns.
You can order them online, have
them shipped right to your home.
No background check, no federal
regulation like modern guns.
But it's still a deadly weapon,
theoretically.
Absolutely capable of causing
harm, but legally it's treated
more like a historical artifact
or collectible than a regulated
gun, the analysis concludes.
This anonymous vividly shows how
legal definitions can be
arbitrary and rooted in
regulatory convenience rather
than actual danger.
So the classification isn't
always about how dangerous it
is.
Not necessarily.
It's about how it's classified
for regulation, which can create
these distinctions that don't
always line up with common sense
or history or even the intent of
the Second Amendment.
It definitely complicates public
understanding.
OK, so if you're digging into
all this, the numbers, the
narratives, the history, the
really intricate legal
framework, yeah.
What does this all mean for you,
the listener, and how you
understand the American gun
debate?
It's clearly not as simple or
one-dimensional as the headlines
often make it seem.
That's really the core take away
from all the material we've gone
through.
The debate is so often framed as
the stark choice, right safety
versus freedom, irreconcilable.
But the reality, as we've
explored, is just far more
complex, much more nuanced.
We've seen nearly half a billion
guns coexist with what the
analysis describes as a
relatively low rate of misuse
relative to their sheer numbers.
That directly challenges the
simple idea that more guns
automatically means more
violence everywhere.
It forces you to rethink that
causal link.
And it's strongly emphasizes
those concluding points from the
sources that the vast majority
of firearm owners are
responsible, law abiding
citizens.
And maybe surprisingly, the laws
in many states have actually
become more permissive, not more
restrictive.
And crucially, the Constitution
continues to anchor this right
to bear arms as a fundamental,
fiercely defended hedge against
potential tyranny.
Right.
The technologies changed, yes,
but the legal and cultural
landscape around this deep
rooted right has also shifted
significantly.
So the analysis ultimately
concludes by reinforcing that
firearms themselves aren't the
sole problem.
They're instruments, tools
within a really complex societal
context.
Exactly.
The fundamental issues if we're
serious about tackling violence
effectively, compassionately,
they lie in addressing the huge
challenges of mental illness,
dismantling pervasive gang
culture, confronting those
underlying social conditions,
poverty, lack of opportunity,
systemic issues that tragically
breed violence.
Until we tackle those deeper,
harder root causes.
The numbers reflect violence
will likely persist regardless
of how we try to spin them with
aggregated stats or fear driven
narratives.
Which brings us to a final
provocative thought, one that
really lingers after sifting
through all this data and
context.
The right to bear arms remains
what it always was, a safeguard,
not merely a hobby.
When you truly consider that
perspective, that this right is
viewed by its proponents,
enshrined in law is a vital
check on power, a final defense
of liberty and how that shapes
the whole conversation.
It really prompts you to Mull
over the huge implications of
context, statistical breakdown,
and historical intent in public
discourse.
What stands out most to you when
you consider all these different
layers?
It's certainly a lot to think
about, and it definitely
reframes how we might approach
future discussions on this
critical, very human topic.